[Applause]
where's the shooter at the inside
for the first time we're getting a look
at the dramatic moments after a deadly
shooting inside of Florida Walmart body
camera video shows First Responders
arrived to the scene of what they
believe is an active shooter situation
law and crime Network obtained the
nearly 10 hours of body camera footage
this week stemming from the July 19th
incident it happened in a Florida City
Florida Walmart about an hour Southwest
of Miami Witnesses said they heard as
many as six gunshots go off before two
men were shot and injured video shows
officers arrive on the scene gearing up
for an active shooter threat running
through the stores with long guns in
hand
[Applause]
open
hold on
radio
hello
um
[Applause]
video shows an officer approached the
nail salon inside Walmart where one
victim later identified as 22 year old
Nathaniel Baez is laying on the ground a
woman can be heard screaming and praying
for help
stay with me come on wake up buddy
foreign
[Music]
a second victim was shot and injured by
a stray bullet but survived Baez however
died as a result of his injuries
officials later determined an argument
had broken out between two groups of
three people each before the shooting at
some point a gun was drawn and fired it
by us his relative explained the
situation to First Responders on the
scene
that way
over here
I don't know
right there like four people walking to
your race
okay stay here stay here stay here
[Applause]
all right here foreign
stay back
family was the one that got shot
[Applause]
meanwhile officials search for a suspect
asking Witnesses what the gunman looked
like
entrance
thank you
here if you want let's say I'm a subject
for someone bleeding where they need
rescue I need everybody to stay out
there
yeah
um
address
one of those engines
foreign
black
short haircut
and a scruffy Little Beard
oh black short haircuts
eventually baez's family is escorted out
of Walmart
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
we have um
foreign
oh no yes
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
they are checking the back warehouses on
the east side of the building down
um
[Music]
body camera video shows baez's family
again explaining what led up to the
deadly shooting
[Applause]
foreign
officials Tracked Down the accused
shooter 25-year-old Steve lesson and
take him into custody
nobody asked me
to call him
you're not getting arrested or nothing I
don't know what's going on yeah
so did you provide any
but First Responders continue to get
reports of multiple shooters
because they mentioned all the shoes
guys go on that side go on this side
twenty-year-old Roberto Dio Andre
Acevedo and 21 year old Jamari cast in
Hodge were also arrested on the scene
they now face battery charges video
shows less than maintained though he was
the only one to fire any shots
uh
[Applause]
Hispanic males three Hispanic males
video then shows less than going in and
out of the squad car before requesting a
change with his handcuffs
man
um I'll get another unit to give me
another heck of I only have one
I got you just like I said I get another
unit here and give me another haircuts
[Music]
oh oh
he's just too tired
Marissa they still clean the Walmart
once they done I have another officer
here I'll get another hangover so right
now you have to wait
that's not a problem but we got there's
other people in there you know
so
yeah
no it's too it's too it's too what's
your name bro I got you I have another
option coming right now
secured the right way listen don't say I
just need I just need these cups to be a
little bit you got another handcuff
can I use a hangover
all right come on
eventually leston is removed from the
scene
not too far from here
foreign
he spends about two hours in the back of
a squad car before he's removed for the
final time just asking can you put the
cuff in the front
how many cars we got on right now
as possible right it's not comfortable
at all no
oh my God
right now
35 degrees
lest and now thesis charges of
second-degree murder and attempted
felony murder right now he's being held
in the Miami-Dade County Jail without
bond reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie